so what happens when you know you guys
are about you're like 10 minutes out
from going live five minutes out from
going live and then it's not happening
what do they tell you what's going
through your mind as that's happening I
mean it's uh
we were all planning for a really
Monumental moment you know and so when
you have all this prep you have this
your mind getting your mindset right
getting your body right we're talking to
each other you know we're trying to fill
out the vibe we're trying to make sure
we come in prepared that hesitation
definitely uh it catches you off guard
and um you know at points in time we
were like we just wish this would start
already yeah um we're trying to keep
each other Lively dancing I mean hanging
out yeah and I think ultimately like we
had a good time with it and I think when
it started off we handled it the right
way yeah of course I mean it was a good
show regardless does anybody from the
crew come out and say like hey here's
what's happening like did they tell you
why what was the what was the reason I
mean
just this season is the reason we broke
the internet season is the reason we
both internet I mean we were just
patiently waiting that that's all it was
we were ready we were ready to get
started we were excited for everybody to
see the live reunion so yeah yeah things
happen yeah nobody was like
it's like a light went out or the stream
is like we can't figure out the
bandwidth I mean we're I mean
our our part of this is really just to
tell our story everything else is
outside of our control yeah did the
nerves start to sink in a little bit I
mean you guys had a great story to tell
so I can't imagine you guys getting
progressively more nervous over the
course of that hour while the show is
delayed but like what was going through
your mind
well we were a little or at least I was
a little bit nervous before we started
but then like after we were waiting for
a little bit I was like oh no this is
good like I just wanted to stick to our
story and celebrating love because
that's what this show is all about
knowing you know what you were in for
and they were going live at five o'clock
and then five o'clock comes and you're
not live and five o'clock becomes six
o'clock what was going on in your mind
between five and six were you like like
a boxer ready to fight who was then like
told nope back to the dressing room for
an hour I was just anxious I just wanted
to I wanted to get things off my chest I
wanted to be able to have that
conversation with everyone and I just I
honestly just wanted to get it over with
like I wanted to have everyone you know
be able to say their piece and so I was
a little anxious but it happened anybody
say why it was because like internet
yeah I don't know I mean the show's been
a huge
a huge mess like drama social media I'm
not shocked that of course it ended in
some sort of chaos like that it was hard
to wrap your head around in a way I was
just like what like we're crashing
Netflix servers we're crashing servers
around the world like there was a little
bit of Pride I was like yeah
but I don't know it was it was weird but
I was grateful for the moment to like
kind of recalibrate because we were all
so like nervous going in um so yeah it
gave us a chance to kind of settle our
nerves I just think people were really
excited to see me get roasted so the
inner the server got backed up so you
know I mean it got we they got what they
wanted the show came on so but took a
minute we were just told just sit tight
yeah yeah and what does that do to your
mindset when you're like you're ready
you're ready to go and then you're off
the starter block oh yeah it's it's like
uh
it's like when uh when a field goal
kicker is ice in football like the code
the coach on the opposing team comes in
and calls a quick timeout yeah it's like
the nerves it's just kind of get settled
and you gotta re-re restart it restart
it restarted so yeah it was it was
difficult but I feel like we all managed
it pretty well they were up to update
with like times and stuff and we you
know we are so comfortable around all
these people that we're with right or
most of them right and so we were just
hanging out and just waiting and it was
fine I mean we had a great technical
team I mean they got everything back
online really quick uh and uh it just
goes to show like how many people are
into the show so this kind of thing only
happens for like Game of Thrones or
House of the Dragon like really big
shows that like people are really
excited for that crashes services and
now you guys are a part of that how did
that feel how did like what is that I
mean obviously you guys have been going
through this you've been seeing people's
messages and DMS and maybe even in in
your personal lives but tonight you got
kind of concrete proof of that like how
many people are are following this show
and this journey yeah I think it's like
such a beautiful thing to be able to
share our story with the world I mean to
have that level of like impact is so
humbling and beautiful and I want us to
continue using that for good things so